muchas veces en química encontraremos
moléculas diferentes que están
constituidas por los mismos átomos por
ejemplo cada una de estas dos moléculas
tiene cuatro carbonos 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
entonces si escribimos su fórmula
química tenemos c4 y después las dos
tienen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 hidrógenos las dos moléculas
tienen la fórmula química c 4 h 10 pero
aún así son moléculas diferentes porque
miren aquí tenemos un carbono que está
unido a otros 3 carbonos y un hidrógeno
mientras que por acá no puedo encontrar
ningún carbono que esté unido a otros 3
carbonos hay carbonos unidos a otros 2
carbonos pero ninguno está unido a otros
3 carbonos
que la forma en la que están unidos los
átomos es diferente y cuando tenemos una
situación como ésta en la que tenemos el
mismo número de átomos es decir la misma
fórmula química pero las moléculas son
diferentes ya sea por la forma en que
están unidas o por la forma que tienen a
esto le llamaremos isómeros un isómero y
somero tiene la misma fórmula química
misma fórmula química pero tiene
diferentes enlaces diferentes enlaces o
forma
y orientación entonces por acá tenemos
diferentes enlaces es decir se forman
diferentes estructuras a este tipo de
isómeros se les conoce como isómeros
estructurales
tienen los mismos átomos pero las
estructuras que forman son diferentes
estos son isómeros estructurales ahora
analicemos este par estos no son
isómeros estructurales aunque miren
tienen los mismos constituyentes por
ejemplo los dos tienen cuatro carbonos y
los dos tienen uno dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete ocho los dos tienen ocho
hidrógenos así que las dos moléculas son
c 4 h 8 y miren a simple vista parece
que se unen de una forma muy similar por
ejemplo del lado izquierdo se ven
iguales y del lado derecho tenemos un
carbono unido a otro carbono que a su
vez está unido a tres hidrógenos por acá
también tenemos un carbono unido a otro
carbono que está unido a tres hidrógenos
y este es un carbono unido a un
hidrógeno y es
que también es un carbono unido a un
hidrógeno así que la estructura es muy
parecida todo está unido de la misma
forma pero tal vez ya vieron la
diferencia por acá del lado derecho este
s h 3 se encuentra hacia abajo mientras
que este se h 3 se encuentra hacia
arriba y tal vez me diga ok pero si al
final todas las moléculas se están
moviendo y pueden rotar bueno si esta
molécula pudo haber rotado hacia abajo
para convertirse en lo que tenemos
arriba pero eso solo pasaría si
tuviéramos un enlace simple un enlace
simple permite que haya rotación pero un
doble enlace no permite que haya
rotación al contrario el doble enlace
fija a las moléculas en la misma
posición por eso estas son dos moléculas
diferentes en la molécula de arriba los
grupos ch3 se encuentran hacia abajo o
dicho de otra manera se encuentran del
mismo lado
al doble enlace mientras que por acá se
encuentran en lados diferentes entonces
a este tipo de isómeros en donde tenemos
los mismos constituyentes y la misma
estructura se les conoce como estéreo
isómeros aquí nos interesa más cómo
están acomodados en tres dimensiones no
solamente a que están unidos y bueno
este también es un ejemplo de estéreo y
somero porque miren este carbono está
unido a los mismos átomos en ambos casos
entonces todos estos son ejemplos de
estéreo isómeros y en particular a esta
variación de estéreo isómeros se les
conoce como iso mary a 6 trans si es
cuando los dos grupos se encuentran del
mismo lado cis y trans es cuando los
grupos se encuentran en lados opuestos
respecto al doble enlace
estos son isómeros 6
trans isómeros 6 trans que también se
conocen como isómeros geométricos
y sombreros geométricos
entonces cuando hablamos de isómeros cis
trans o geométricos
estamos hablando de esta parte que son
un subconjunto de estéreo y sombreros y
finalmente qué está pasando aquí aquí no
tenemos un doble enlace ni podemos
hablar de cis o trans pero observen que
aquí el carbono está unido a un flúor
cloro y bromo e hidrógeno y por acá
flúor bromo cloro e hidrógeno entonces
en que son diferentes
bueno si tratamos de superponer los
podremos ver que es imposible porque
estas son imágenes especulares es decir
son el reflejo de la otra y como tenemos
cuatro constituyentes diferentes
no podemos superponer esta molécula
sobre esta y debido a eso tienen
propiedades químicas diferentes así que
así que estas dos moléculas que también
son un subconjunto de estéreo isómeros
recuerden los estéreo isómeros tienen
que ver con la posición
las moléculas en tres dimensiones y
cuando tenemos dos imágenes especulares
que no se pueden sobreponer les vamos a
llamar enantiómero aquí tenemos dos en
anti hombros
en antia tiene de la palabra griega en
antes que significa opuesto aquí tenemos
dos moléculas que son opuestas entre sí
no se pueden superponer son reflejos
entonces todas estas moléculas son
diferentes variaciones de isómeros
claramente podemos ver que estas son dos
moléculas diferentes que están unidas de
forma diferente pero incluso los
isómeros cis trans tienen diferentes
propiedades químicas y a veces pueden
ser tan diferentes que incluso una puede
existir en un sistema biológico pero la
otra no una puede ser buena para la
salud y la otra no y lo mismo ocurre con
los enantiómero si una molécula puede
ser biológicamente activa de alguna
forma pero la otra no